plötzlich war der stern in 69 46 bh ein
verschwunden nichts erinnerte mehr daran
dass er mal da war und das war die für
die forscherinnen und forscher der ohio
state university in den usa extrem
verblüffen
denn was sie eigentlich erwartet hatten
waren zumindest die reste einer
supernova dem letzten aufbäumen eines
sterns bevor er zu einem schwarzen loch
zusammenstürzen
so müsste jedenfalls laut der aktuellen
lehrmeinung der astrophysik sein aber da
war einfach nicht beziehungsweise
nachdem wir mit dem weltraumteleskop
hubble und zweiter nachgeschaut hatten
einfach nur ein schwarzes loch aber wie
konnte der stern ohne eine supernova zu
einem starken noch werden was war
seltsames passiert und welche
konsequenzen hat diese entdeckung jetzt
wichtig zum fixen herzlich willkommen so
eine entstehung eines schwarzen loches
hatten wissenschaftler noch nicht
beobachten plötzlich verschwand ein
stern und ein schwarzes loch war da
wirklich das was astrophysiker bisher
geleert hatten ein schwarzes loch
entsteht demnach aus einem stern der
mindestens die dreifache mutter oder
auch die 8 fache masse der sonne hat so
ganz einig scheint sich da die
astrophysik nicht zu sein
sterne haben eine ganz besondere
eigenschaft eigentlich müssten sie
aufgrund ihrer masse zu einem schwarzen
loch zusammenstürzen
doch die kernfusion reaktionen in ihrem
kern wirkt dem gravitationskräfte du
stark entgegen dass das nicht passiert
wenn aber der brennstoff für die
kernfusion aufgebraucht ist nimmt dieser
gegendruck irgendwann so stark ab dass
die materie in sich zusammenstürzt und
eigentlich sorgt die schockwelle die
dabei entsteht erst mal für eine
explosion des sterns eine supernova
ständig können solche supernovae im
weltraum beobachtet werden
ich hab mal überschlagen das ist bei
einer millionen galaxien in welt kommen
das war das ergebnis der jüngsten
schätzungen von wissenschaftlern und
wissenschaftlerinnen der university
nottingham aus dem letzten jahr müssten
es hunderte super nova jede sekunde im
weltall geben aber was ist wenn es bei
dem zusammenstoß von großen stern gar
keine supernova gibt
bislang dachten wir dass ein stern nur
dann ein schwarzes loch erzeugen kann
wenn er als supernova explodiert wenn
das auch ohne detonation erfolgen kann
würde dies erklären warum wir von den
massereichsten sterne keine super norway
sehen das sagt astronom christopher
kochanek mitglied der vorderen gruppe
der ohio state university das heißt dass
ein stern auch vollkommen ohne explosion
ohne supernova einfach mir nicht wir
nicht ohne große spuren zu hinterlassen
zu einem schwarzen loch zusammenstürzen
kann
das hätte erhebliche konsequenzen wenn
es so viele supernovae pro sekunde
besser gibt also hunderte wieviel
schwarze löcher entstehen dann erst und
sie könnten viel größer als bisher
gedacht sein wenn es nicht keine
supernova eine sternenexplosion gibt bei
der ein riesiger teil der materie im
weltall geschleudert wird und nicht ins
schwarze loch stürzt wenn das also bei
massereichen sternen nicht passiert dann
entstehen beim kollaps eines stern viel
größere schwarze löcher
solche wie letztes jahr bei der
entdeckung der gravitationswellen
entdeckt hat das heißt die masse der
schwarzen löcher im weltall wäre auch
viel größer als gedacht moment wären wir
dann nicht wieder bei der these dass die
dunkle materie aus schwarzen löchern
besteht also ich halte euch auf jeden
fall zu diesem thema auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein video zu diesem thema
verpassen wollt dann rückt man ein abo
aufs auge und vergesst nicht wenn euch
wirklich kein video durch die lappen
gehen wollten
auch die glocke ja ihr geht es weiter
mit dem video mit der these dass die
dunkle materie aus schwarzen löchern
bestehen könnte das ist wirklich
ziemlich verblüffend wenn er das auch so
spannend finde es gibt einfach drauf und
ich sage jetzt wie immer am ende jedes
videos bis dann bleibt dran